yeah you should have uh [ __ ] matt host a
segment
we thought about it it's very political
out here with that guy yeah with him
yeah just because he's like such a crazy
ass gangbanger it's like there's there's
there's a line between like
a gang member somebody who like is in a
gang but is not out here just talking
crazy [ __ ] about everybody else who's
another but [ __ ] mack is like a
different level where he's extremely
aggressive and and you know it creates a
lot of problems with other hosts on the
network and stuff i remember seeing like
snoop dogg come out with the new
album and [ __ ] it had i mean years ago
now but
but uh
probably not 10 years ago and he was
talking about like blue handkerchief
coming out of my back pocket and i
didn't even know he was a crit before
that yeah no i do i didn't know there's
before that but
but i remember thinking
my
initial just sort of gut reaction was
like
man snoop you've come so far like you
don't need to be talking about blue
handkerchieves like does that is that a
fair thought
nah because i think somebody like snoop
dogg like like gangbanging is whatever
you make of it right like like you could
be a [ __ ] and you could be literally
like going out and trying to shoot your
enemies every day or you could be a 40
year old dude who's like yeah i was a
[ __ ] coming up or even like i know dudes
are young guys who are like clearly
identified with a certain neighborhood
or whatever and it's not some negative
thing it's not like they've got to fight
people or shoot people or whatever now
the reality is for like most young
people that there are a lot of negative
consequences that come from it but
somebody like snoop i mean even at the
super bowl
he's throwing up [ __ ] seas at the at
the at the super bowl you know like
the version of crippen that he's pushing
is not a negative one it's just love for
his
community so he's like
a hell's angel that's not the one
percent exactly where it's like he
appreciates the culture and he respects
it and he has love for it but it's not
like he's endorsing any of the
negativity that comes with it you know
all right that's how i would think of it
at least i think that clip was awesome
but not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what i've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions which
is out september 27th and if you
pre-order it right now you can get the
autographed copy so get on it man
pre-order my book it's not going to
waste your time because i'm proven dude
new york times bestseller my first
book's five star rated on amazon and i
have no doubt this one will be two so
get the autographed copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude